je sais
à
je
m
[Musique]
à
oh
pas plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez vous encore au don flambeau
des soirées au sein de l'antenne ou de
broderies anglaises pour y apporter le
confort de ses jolies silhouettes avec
de l'argent gagné pour vous défouler et
injures les gens aimaient le collier
chez les hommes sont fréquents et n'y a
pas de grand
[Musique]
lors des galas la perceuse ou bossus eux
la matière en un an prix moto aux
environnements autre personnage central
les grandes familles de planteurs
martiniquais je veux nommer la tarte
dans celles qui élèvent tous les enfants
et puis va les accompagner à tous les
moments importants de leur existence
donc c'est à aujourd'hui ya présenté le
nouveau né elle vit sur l'habitation et
nous avons une date qui porte une tenue
très particulière puisque c'est une
place avec une tenue digne alors le
cardage c'est simplement la façon de
redonner un coup de fraîcheur un tissu
petit peu usagé on venait de perdre avec
le mélange de gomme arabique et 2 et de
pigments et notamment que cette fois il
s'agit de l'autre et avec ce mélange
d'envié france gilbert les bandes et qui
vont permet de redonner le tout nouveau
visage à des tissus qui est un peu
défraîchi lataste personnages importants
vaio legrand par la richesse de ses
bijoux tout ce qu'elle peut gagner et
desrosiers théorisée par dons sous forme
d'or ne crée d'or est donc ici on a une
la divine d'habitation friches l arrivée
de nombreux enfants et elle était
largement est intéressé elle va jusqu'à
corner sa coiffe de bijoux
c'est une tradition qui nous vient
également les indiens qui sont venus
bien plus tard à la matinée méfions
apporter cette façon de d'augmenter nos
pouvoirs additionnels
je n'habite pas été spontanés de la
société m'intriguait fait 18e je donne
un coup moins de revenir sur scène
mondiale
et si tu veux un petit peu de musique
ont terminé le dernier monstre
à voir vous même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
fait marquant
[Musique]
à la croisée des mondes
le lobby ou une dernière apporte
[Musique]
remettre remettre au goût ou quoi faire
vivre la tradition
je pense que je pense que c'est en cours
est ici et la présence d'un aussi grand
nombre de personnes en europe dont
combats précédents je voudrais rappeler
que c'est quand même un combat de
militants de défense de la tradition des
cultures de la musique aussi
nous avons commencé aussi bien sûr pour
la musique de lalo taken défendons mais
aussi nous défendons les vêtements
fonctionnels et nous lui disons nous le
répétons tous les jours que nos
traditions nos vêtements sont pas des
vêtements de carnaval et par conséquent
ils pourront remettre au goût du jour la
culture mais aussi les vêtements
comporter
les aînés et quoi nous continuons à
porter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
a bordeaux
[Musique]
alors
à
ce fut avant tout
[Musique]